The Boeing company proposes a
personal transportation system,
or PTS, which provides point
to point transportation
for individuals using
a number of taxi
like personal aerial vehicles.
Our goal in model based
embedded in robotic systems
is to have humans and
robots collaborate together
to achieve high level goals
defined by human operators.
We demonstrate the capability
of our architecture
on a personal transportation
system scenario,
where the personal
aerial vehicle takes off
from Provincetown
and heads to Bedford.
On the way, there are
multiple nearby airports,
and each airport has a no fly
zone that must be avoided.
The user inputs the
trip specification
by highlighting start
goal, alternative landing
sites, and no fly zones using
the graphical user interface.
The pike module calculates the
corresponding visibility graph
and the shortest path from
the start to the goal.
If the remaining fuel
capacity is not sufficient,
pike generates the path to the
closest alternative landing
site.
The generated path
is communicated
to Sulu and the users through
the graphical interface.
Here, the GUI updates
the real time location
of the plane while in the corner
is a flight simulation using
X-Plane.
A personal aerial vehicle takes
off from Provincetown Municipal
Airport.
The architecture automatically
navigates the vehicle
to the user specified
destination.
The system is also
capable of adapting
to a changing environment.
For example, if a storm
approaches the vehicle,
it will automatically replan
the path to avoid the storm.
Of course, the replanned path
respects all the no fly zones.
The system keeps
updating the plan
based on the current best
available information.
This demonstration
shows the capabilities
of our autonomous system in
providing safe and optimal
paths in a dynamic environment.